so look at page 37 with me there's this
enormous table and um I actually going
to draw a part of it so that I can refer
to it in a second but first let's just
look at it okay what is this thing over
the top all the roads you can see it
says interest rate per period right and
then across the left hand side it says
huge it may well be like years or months
or something like that okay and what
does it mean look up for a second see
this see this process that we did to
build these numbers it took us a while
into like we had to do this working then
we had to get a calculators out and you
got to do it many times and so on and
it's quite a time-consuming process
right these tables are designed to speed
up that process right make it a lot
simpler and you can crunch numbers out
much more quickly okay so here's the way
it works we looked at $1,000 okay $1,000
what we want to think is okay example
$1,000 and we went up to six years we
have to six years
okay so $1000 six percent Interest six
years now here's the way that you read
this table right you say what's the
interest rate per period per year will
you read across you've got columns four
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten percent so the column we're
after is six percent okay six do you see
that right so I'm actually going to draw
the six percent column just so I can I
can refer to it okay so you have six
percent at the top of the column and
then you've got a bunch of numbers
underneath some decimals okay I'm gonna
write some of them you've got 1.06 1.1
okay and it keeps going right now
these roads are also labeled on the
left-hand side on the table there's one
two three four five six okay and the way
it works is rather than go through all
these calculations they say if you just
want to work out an amount of interest
for an amount of time okay all you have
to do is go to the appropriate cell in
the table and take your amount and just
multiply by that number so example if
wanted to know what it was artists it's
easy to go 1,000 right times and then
you just go to 6% is this column and six
years is this row so you just go one
point four one nine okay so what's that
well you just move the decimal ways
three times that's one four one nine now
one second we worked this out before
we actually did it we've our calculators
in the wind through the whole thing
this is the number we calculated
something's wrong what's wrong what
they've done is they have rounded okay
now tell you why they've rounded have a
look at these numbers in fact all of
them should be familiar every single one
because they all correspond to kisi they
correspond to these numbers that we
calculated but we calculated it to the
nearest cent right okay but these is
calculated to the nearest four
significant figures right we've looked
at seen you guys before right can you
see every single one four digits four
digits four digits and so on right how
many seen you two used to be calculate
my count
for example this last row right I count
one two three four five six they're all
significant none of them are approximate
we didn't round off until the very last
one right so what you're doing here
right these numbers match those in an
approximate way okay so it's far start
but it's not as accurate that's
the trade-off right in fact that's
usually the way it is recalculations you
can do them quicker but you'll have a
margin of error okay so that's how you
can use this table to do the same
calculation by quicker turn over the
page XS to D this is the last one it
investing now it'll actually help you if
you've got a if you're next to someone
and you can um you can have two
textbooks there the reason why is
because you sort of need to have this
page as well as this page like at the
same time so it's a bit of pain clicking
back and forth so if you want to in a
second move and have a second textbook
that might be useful to you but let's
have a look at the very first question
find the companion just earned on an
investment they've got this example
$12,000 seven percent per annum five
years so now look at the table look at
the table these two numbers over here
seven percent and five es they tell you
where to look okay so five percent tells
you the column right so you tracked
across until you find five years five
percent okay
and then it says well I keep reading
wrong switches others seven percent so
you going all the way over okay and then
you go down to five years so you got to
pick a row and a column it looks to me
like seven percent five years that
number is can you see it one point four
OH three 1.43 that's the number that
corresponds to seven percent five years
so now we need to do to work out the
final about is take your twelve thousand
and multiply by that magic number and do
it so you get your calculator out
you put your right foot in to shake it
on top and you get one six eight three
six right and zero says now again be
careful right because they have rounded
it this is not going to be exactly right
if we went through this process we would
get it more precise but I wouldn't have
to round off to the nearest dollar or
something like that okay but this is
what they have given us and it's going
to be pretty close okay just for the
sake of it I'm gonna work it out like
I'm gonna do use the proper the real for
the month right it would be this twelve
thousand times 1.07 to the power five
one so they're approximation was a
little bit generous wasn't it we
actually don't get quite that about
we're a few dollars off but we're in the
right ballpark aren't we that's pretty
close